[Music]
what is going on there reject nation we
are going to watch today from the
youtube channel cinematic capture a cad
bane deep fake one that is more likening
to star wars the clone wars and how we
saw him in the bad batch after cabin's
appearance while there was a lot of
excitement that cabin is finally in live
action there was a bit of a discourse
over his appearance and some people were
upset with the way he actually looked um
it just ruined the whole show it ruined
everything no one liked it anymore boba
fett boba fett entirely no i want to
check this out man kat vane is such an
awesome character and i would i like the
way he looked i would love to see what
it would look like if he did look more
more animated for him
[Music]
i'm sorry i didn't catch your name
i'd be careful where i was sticking my
nose if i were you
that's more of the blue eye imagine a
friendly advice or a threat
wow
that's pretty crazy they tweak his head
shape a little bit too he's a
cold-blooded killer who worked with the
empire
face is slumbered you tell your spice
runner's tattooing it's clothes for
business
this planet's seen enough violence
oh this would be fun to talk about i
should have never given up your armor it
was kind of blurry too where i was
sticking my nose if i were you i even
redid the teeth yeah
so you have mouths way lower
boba fett
is a cold-blooded killer
for the empire that actually looks
pretty crazy damn that looks great
holy [ __ ]
that looks awesome you're hired for the
next season
this planet seen enough violence
you should have never given up your
armor
wow
that was great yeah that was really well
done it was pretty impressive when that
came out i was excited to see cabane and
i i still like the way it looks you know
we were watching you rockstars easter
egg breakdown eric voss was saying how
he really loved the appearance of him
like how he is a little bit more washed
out how like time has really caught up
with him being in this desert landscape
and how with his it's like what was the
phrase he used to know how to like dried
him out yeah dried him out or
metaphorically or it almost is like he's
been sun bleached out in the desert for
so long you know because it seems like
from the places he's popped up in the
clone wars and in bad batch like he's in
a lot of other locales that aren't quite
so hot and desolate and bright all the
time yeah i mean if you look at what you
know especially what cinematic capture
did here obviously the first that comes
to mind is the fact that he is a lot
more blue and that's kind of what i
expected when i when i was seeing cab
bane starting to walk in the frame the
eyes are not as wide also the face is
definitely a lot slimmer i think he did
some work on the teeth i've heard some
people compared to like a little bit of
butt teeth
some people really like crapping on the
design and i i thought it was great i
think also too the breathing tubes yeah
i think like more so in the animated
form sometimes they're actually coming
backwards a little bit more but here
they they fall down more yeah and the
actual
appearance also the nose is definitely a
lot bigger as well in the actual version
of the live action now versus what they
did here was more little slim especially
because his face does fall slimmer too
well yeah i feel like that's what a lot
of what they did here was probably
remove you know when you're making up an
actor no matter how impressive you're
only able to build on top of and build
up so especially looking at the side by
side you could tell like okay that's
where they had to conceal a nose that's
where they had to work with the shape of
the actor's head yeah to kind of convey
the idea of narrowness and convey the
alien quality while still working with
what you've got whereas yeah here it's
like you're able to move the mouth way
down low you're able to kind of compress
where his nose mound is here's the thing
i keep coming back to maybe because it's
you know like when you think of things
like area 51 for example oh that's out
in the desert and that's where they have
aliens kept these these extraterrestrial
beings who might look like a humanoid
appearance but they're not human yeah
and that's what i felt the live-action
campaign evoked so much of when you see
him he he feels like an extraterrestrial
being yeah which is what he is
yeah yeah he is he is dead
you know i mean this is star wars rooks
born in the galaxy he's in stuff he's an
alien
yeah he is an alien so i that's why i
think i personally just love the design
of him i still feel like it evokes those
menacing grim you know western vibes
that cabbane is supposed to evoke
overall the the emotion that it's
supposed to uh instill in an audience
member i still think is there and of
course bringing back the original voice
actor definitely helps that's something
i heard a lot of people complain about
too not fully matching up because of
like minimal movement because of
prosthetics but i'm like guys i thought
it was great
i mean it sounds better than it would
have sounded just using set i assumed
that was a loop or a dub or whatever but
yeah i mean i thought that was actually
pretty well achieved given that yeah if
you're looking at all the effects and
that's what you're focusing on you can
tell that yeah this guy's got teeth put
in and all that stuff but i thought it
played really well it reminded me of
when some people were complaining about
ahsoka tano live action when they first
saw rosario dawson or lekku's if i'm not
mistaken when you first see her when
she's young the lekus are short and then
by the time you see her rebels are a lot
longer i don't remember what the
justification was but when she you know
they don her in live action the lakus
are nowhere near the length that you
would imagine especially coming off the
last time you saw her in rebels you
would imagine them to be longer so yeah
it's like a comparison thing from
animated to live action and especially
when you are doing a thing where you're
plucking them out of an enemy i just
plug them on a cartoon however i i feel
like these choices are intentional for a
reason especially when dave filoni the
one who created these characters
bringing them to live action he's the
one doing it and i think the choice is
like they're gonna run this by him and
he's going to have a say in how it's all
done this version of cat bane feels like
there's there's a little bit more of it
it feels a little more humanoid yeah
some people thought it's a little
cartoony i feel like either way you're
gonna wind up with it looking cartoony
all that being said
this looks
that's the thing awesome that that is
still pretty chilling and badass to
bring the life of like oh so they could
have done that well yeah they could have
still done the one that looks exactly
like out of the animation well yeah
that's the thing is like this is fun to
look at side by side to me because it's
not as much like the luke skywalker
mandalorian season two where it's like
oh this could have looked better in a
more like you know human convincing type
of way this is like yes it could have
looked a bit more accurate to the
original model but i yeah i thought the
way they realized it here is yeah those
things have to be intentional the amount
of artistry they put in part of the fun
too of adapting any animation character
is having slight changes when you bring
it to real life especially as a
practical effect so all right guys well
what was your overall thoughts on it do
you think did it still work for you did
you fall on the side where you thought
it looked weird leave your thoughts down
below uh either way i thought this was a
really wonderfully done rendered a more
closely accurate version of the
animation
uh subscribe leave a like button hey
let's do it
everett pixel might baker pixel might
your moniker of choice came to mind
watching this video because this was all
about the might of pixels the artistry
that can be hewn and rendered with the
digital space and hey i don't know if
that's where you work or that's what you
do for a living but you bring us much
light just by being here just by showing
your support everett baker and uh hey i
would be thrilled if you were to show up
as a silhouette on the horizon to come
and pull up some business with me i
would be like oh damn this guy means
business and i am here to attend you
know i wouldn't fire on you i wouldn't
draw i would be like let me listen to
what this guy has to say because he
could probably kick my ass across
tatooine
anyway buddy i hope you're doing well
happy 2022 and uh we'll catch you next
month catch you next month
[Music]